is it safe to call this a vacation
kendall jenner shares a rare look at her
getaway with devin booker as the model
and nba player take on the great
outdoors
over the weekend kendall caught devin
showing off his axe throwing skills and
shared this snap of being whisked away
on a zip line giving a peek at her
attire kendall and devin's vacation
comes amid the news of their split in
june with the shorts telling e.t at the
time quote kendall feels like they're on
different paths and quote they have had
discussions about their future but they
are not on the same page but the source
did admit the possibility of them
getting back together despite the
breakup devin and kendall have clearly
been hanging out since
a few weeks ago kendall shared a
mysterious selfie on insta of the pair
all dressed up while attending a wedding
and following fourth of july weekend a
source told et that the two spent the
holiday together in the hamptons and
quote had a really fun time
adding quote their hectic schedules
sometimes get in the way of their
relationship but they have a lot of love
for each other
it's not always easy
kendall first confirmed she and the
baller were an item after months of
speculation at the reunion special that
capped off keeping up with the
kardashians run
so what's happening with you and devin
booker
um he's my boyfriend so when the
family's news show premiered on hulu
fans sort of expected devin to pop up
i'm so over there scott
but he was nowhere to be seen in season
one something kendall kind of prepped us
for when e.t sat down with the model and
her sisters ahead of the series debut i
think like a cool part about kylie and i
growing up on the show um
and something that maybe we don't take
for granted is you know we got to see
things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age i
think both kylie and i kind of knew what
we wanted to keep
off the show or what we wanted to keep
to ourselves and um
yeah i think that it's kind of as simple
as that and you know we learn and again
our boundaries may change one day
depending on the situation but
yeah